[Music]
and here we are with uh robert thomas in
the sunflowers chess club uh during the
sinful cup at this moment happening in
the next building uh robert tell us your
impressions you just came out from there
so how does it feel to be there yeah i
mean it was pretty cool uh definitely
something that i haven't haven't seen
before i've always been a big fan of
chess so
i've been watching them online and on
the streams and stuff but just to be in
that room and kind of feel
feel the
you know all the powerful thinking and
all those plays is uh it's pretty cool
yeah and
my routine for this tournament actually
who is your favorite player
uh you know what i probably followed him
the longest uh just because i know his
name is magnus carlson i think he's uh
he's obviously the best in the world and
someone who i've followed since i was
you know a lot younger than i am now
yeah i mean and also i noticed that you
are checking the games carefully i also
know that you are really decent players
so how happened did you you play chess
i probably play
uh you know i try and play once a week
for at least an hour i played it a lot a
lot more when i was younger but i you
know started to get back into it the
last couple years so i try and get at
least an hour and a week
and just kind of practice a little bit
yeah who taught you to play chess
actually uh i'd say my friends
me and my friends used to play in the
chess club back in elementary school and
i was playing tournaments around our
local city so i i think it was just a
fun way to compete with friends and uh
yeah something that we always uh you
know had a lot of fun doing
yeah and you are here in st blues for
many years already playing for some
lewis blues
hockey team and how does it feel to be
finally instantly cheers club itself
yeah it's something that
obviously co would co would happen so i
couldn't come here earlier but
someplace that always wanted to come and
couldn't be better a better time to come
than having this tournament here so
yeah very excited and definitely a place
left to check out a lot more
yeah i hope so and we're looking forward
to see you again at st louis chess club
as probably will have a chance to play
more games thank you so much for today's
yes
thank you
[Music]